[Music]
going along for the ride with a classic
video game turn TV show is the final
final appearance of a popular Netflix
character a movie based on a Disney
theme park attraction a movie directed
by actually talented YouTube stars and
the return again of a fan favorite
animated series don't get it twisted
it's time for this week's what to watch
I want to hire you pick up a package
bring it back I can make your every wish
come true so John what do you wish for
toilet paper
I think I can do better
three-ply crashing straight into peacock
this week is the new series Twisted
Metal this one is of course based on the
combat vehicle video game that first
debuted in 1995 on Sony's original
PlayStation and anytime we can bring
that bad boy into the conversation makes
it a great reason to check out the
series another reason to get revved up
for Twisted Metal which stars Anthony
Mackey as the lead character John Doe is
that it's officially listed as a
live-action comedy clearly leaning into
the dark humor that the game has become
known for plus it takes place in a
post-apocalyptic world and those are all
the rage right now and because great
things come in threes a third reason to
consider this one is Sweet Tooth no not
the reason you can't shed that extra 10
pounds it's everyone's favorite ice
cream truck driving killer clown from
the game in this case he's voiced by
podcaster star Will Arnett and
physically played by pro wrestler Samoa
Joe and um yeah don't show your kids
we didn't come this far just to abandon
each other
also planting its sword into your
streaming options this week is the
season 3 volume 2 premiere of The
Witcher and while we've told you that
this is the final season for Henry
Cavill in the role of Carol to Rivia
before Liam Hemsworth takes over now
we're down to just his final three
episodes which is of course the first
reason to head over to Netflix another
would be without giving too much away
that season 3 volume 1 ended with a
cliffhanger and you just gotta see what
happens next am I right and speaking of
volume 1 it's coming in with a fresh 78
on the Tomato Meter with the consensus
from critics being that so far it's
paying a fittingly fond farewell to this
particular girl to Rivia gotta do our
boy Henry Wright death lurks around
every corner
God give us a break there's so many bad
people in the world haunt them amen
spooking its way into theaters this week
is the fantasy comedy Haunted Mansion
starring lakeith Stanfield he and the
rest of the loaded cast that includes
Tiffany haddish Owen Wilson Danny DeVito
Rosario Dawson Dan Levy Jared Leto and
Jamie Lee Curtis sheesh the second
reason to catch this one is that it
marks the second theatrical adaptation
of the Disney attraction The Haunted
Mansion the first one came in 2003 with
Eddie Murphy starring and is a rotten 14
on the Tomato Meter we don't talk about
that one so only uphill from there right
there's some great talent behind the
camera as well with director Justin
Simeon best known for his debut dear
white people and writer Kate dippled has
worked on shows like Mad TV and Parks
and Rec Plus movies like The Heat and
the 2016 Ghostbusters reboot in other
words get ready to laugh cannot go for
more than 90 seconds am I clear what
happens after 90 seconds
don't want to stay
[Music]
also speaking to us from theaters is a
supernatural horror flick talk to me and
check this out this is the directorial
debut for twin Australian filmmakers
Danny and Michael Filippo who gained
massive popularity on YouTube with their
intense action comedy videos that's the
first reason to give this one a shot the
second reason is that it's 95 on the
Tomato Meter with about 127 reviews so
far the critics consensus says it has a
gripping story and impressive practical
effects and Spins a terrifically creepy
21st century horror yarn built on
classic foundations say less we're sold
if you need a third reason horror fans
will then get a load of this scary
premise some friends learn how to
conjure Spirits using an embalmed hand
and things get a little out of hand
unleashing terrifying Supernatural
forces yes it's like that one time my
friends and I had a Ouija board and ask
your parents about it kids here look at
this
yeah
stop hiding
okay I'm done and finally fresh fan
making its triumphant return to your TV
is the Animated Series Futurama that's
right it's back again after debuting on
Fox back in 1999 and running for Four
Seasons it was later picked up by Comedy
Central for three more that ended in
2013 and now a decade later Futurama is
headed to Hulu with at least 20 new
episodes which is great reason to tune
in the series came from Simpson's
Creator Matt Groening who's returning
for the latest round of episodes and
he'll be joined by the core voice cast
returning as well which includes Billy
West as Philip J fry and Katie Seagal as
Leela All Good Things plus the show
carries an audience score of 94 and all
the seasons that have enough reviews for
Tomato Meter score which is four of them
are all very fresh that includes the
certified fresh first season where
critics described it as an inventive
funny and sometimes affecting look at
the World of Tomorrow a consensus that
still holds up
and there you have it five picks that
are so good you'll want to pick up a
piece of metal and twist it okay that
wasn't was a bit of a stretch or twist
be sure to let us and your fellow
viewers know in the comments what you
did check out whether it was on this
list or not remember to check out
rottentomanos.com for the latest updates
on scores and reviews for everything
mentioned as well as the movie and TV
World At Large and please check out our
rt25 page at rottentominos.com so you
can vote in our fan fave movie and TV
poll we'll give you an imaginary sticker
okay that's all for today fresh family
until next week stay fresh
[Music]
all right